Hello, children.
Five little monkeys jumping on the bed, one fell off and bumped his head.
Mama called the doctor and the doctor said,...
..."No more monkeys jumping on the bed."
Four little monkeys jumping on the bed, one fell off and bumped his head.
Mama called the doctor and the doctor said,...
..."No more monkeys jumping on the bed."
Three little monkeys jumping on the bed, one fell off and bumped his head.
This is taking too long.
So I will summarize, listen very carefully.
All of the monkeys fall off the bed.
The doctor is slightly frustrated,...
...having repeatedly instructed their mother not to allow them to jump on the bed.
Besides, why is she calling a doctor and not a vet?
This woman is sick and should be committed to a mental institution.
The end.
Sweet dreams, kids.